yes
or if you are the best and nothing else
matters and if you are now all of us and
nothing else matters
it was a time when the glory of God
departed as all
world the signs were small and subtle at
first the tides have been shifting all
around us we wanted to be loyal and
faithful and many of us were but we
wanted other things to security and
success ease and comfort we wanted to be
like the other nations powerful and
victorious we told ourselves that this
is what God wanted for us to that the
land was given through our own
possession to make a bit rocky would
even those of us who have no aspirations
to rule or more than content to enjoy
the privileges that came with it we
praise God for our many blessings as
God's Spirit driven slowly
our worship and our practice in their
people the profits went plunged us back
is the life but we were like fish
following the school without any clear
leader or direction only fear to drive
us and then one day the world as a new
it was lost altogether the glory of God
was the glory of our eyes on our sacred
space was profaned our people were
scattered we found ourselves like fish
hot water just talking about trying to
breathe suddenly we were loose lipped
ruthless and restless we were forgotten
and forsaken all that was dear to us is
now
and derive it it became costly to
continue to live according to our own
identity and what difference
anyway I was gone everywhere we were the
outsider and we will most along again to
something some Roman s begin to say that
one's not so bad it's too dangerous it's
too demanding to continue to hold on to
the old ways the current powers offer
better panel and we were tempted to
train to our songs for our survival our
own children chase after
at the new boss though we felt defeated
we do our God is not our certainty
couldn't be stripped away by any wealth
or power with a board turned in
those who dream this is no mere mobilize
self-deception this was more true than
anything we could possibly imagined or
accomplished for ourselves it was more
real than our only flesh God had
restored us and we knew it it was
already several a complete the future
was real and ready before us just
waiting for us to step into it the
people streamed up on God's holy
mountain we were a people coming home
then our mountain is filled with Lefter
it bubbled up from deep within us shells
of joy washed across our tongues and
issued forth and fountains of blessing
at first we didn't even recognize the
sound it was something a childhood
something of innocence that
others to her joy they saw and turns and
proclaimed the very ones who have mocked
us saying where is your God now they
were the ones who prophesied saying the
Lord has done great things proven that
god is great by all that God has done
for them we were bored returned the
enzyme the light came into the world
like nothing never before the nation saw
the way men walk from blind see the cat
sense had been set free the Lord has
done great things for them it said but
they too were fed the two were healed
they saw and in their singing made to
bikini the board has done great things
for us we have been rescued and restored
we to a more filled with joy we were a
people coming home return to us again oh
god and prove that you are great that
your love is
and university abundant kind of first a
slow stream and seep into the cracks of
our hearts lives then let your justice
roll down like rain sweep us off our
feet embarrass up buoyant and oh the joy
of your desert creatures those ones who
wait for the returning of the streams
year by year the ones who sit for six
months straight by their little tiny
water holes and those that walk it's
been weeks Marcia hundreds of miles
driven only by the memory that they've
been that way before then would know
what it's like to wait and to trust and
to smell rain first time the smell of
hope and we would know what it means to
leap and to dance to seep way down into
that warm mud and it's a spring forth
and splash through the soft surface of
everything that sustains us to eat our
fill of every good thing in that bless
of abundance may the one who sews is
here
shouts of joy but you must teach us sow
your seeds Oh God probably have just
about given up trying we know that we're
also in tears for two so kindness we
must know violence to serve wholeness we
must see brokenness even our own our
eyes well up with her our mouths with
the groaning of the world but let us so
hope for we have known despair to know
what it is so at all we must return to
the land and learn from it what it means
to be a creature to be a partner a lover
and a friend then we would know the joy
of the farmer and harvest the age of the
bag of hands and feed the sweaty face
when the sun kissed skin the feel of the
hands full of beauty and life life that
we tended and prayed for and protect it
but ultimately never produced then
through a no to all and the mystery we
would know how to receive
the gift we would be like those who
dream God you know what happens to the
dreamer someone else to those who stand
is be truth amidst lies the ones who
dare to describe a different way of life
you know what happens but we would stand
up in the long line of prophets because
we know that this life
death our God is not defeated not
department our certainty will not be
stripped away by love or power we know
that nothing can separate us from the
love of God we know that we are rescued
and restored and so make all the world
know that the one who goes going and
we've been carrying the bag of seed that
one too will come coming and rejoicing
carrying the harvest we are the people
who sing this song we are